mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
ja heute meine damen und herren zu einer
weiteren reaktion von mir auf die
wundervolle professionelle serie hilf
mir muss war meine lieben freunde
reagieren wir heute gemeinsam auf die
folge objekt ofili mein sohn ist mit
einer gummipuppe zusammen
ja fragt einfach nicht bevor wir uns
allerdings das video hier jetzt
anschauen würde ich sagen werfen mir
zuvor einen kurzen blick in die
kommentare fakt ist wir gucken es alle
aber hassen es gleichzeitig meine eltern
würden mich in die klinik stecken wenn
ich so wäre diese puppe war heute der
beste schauspieler die psychologen
werden auch immer besser like damit luca
darauf reagiert dass wir zehn erfolge
ach du meine güte das war es mal wieder
komplett das ist mit abstand die
schlechteste folge war
es war ja schon was uns erwarten wird
wir stürzen uns in wenigen sekunden
direkt rein in diese neue hilfe folge
allerdings möchte ich zuvor noch etwas
ganz kurzes sagen und zwar lounge am
montag um 15 uhr drei neue produkte im
luca - shop.de und zwar das erste bunte
smiley kissen was wir je produziert
haben dann ein schwarzer audi mit einem
luxus frottier schriftzug drauf und der
gleiche rudi noch mal in weiß
den habe ich gerade an und ich würde
mich sehr freuen wenn ihr am montag um
15 uhr im shop vorbeischauen würde die
ersten 1000 besteller bekommen eine
signierte autogrammkarte drauf und so zu
der bestellung dabei und jetzt würde ich
sagen schauen uns die folge an hat das
video ist eine sekunde als allererste
was man sieht ist das die folge in köln
aufgenommen wurde warnt sind meine stadt
wieder komplett
sendet hier war endlich mal okay er hat
ein date wenn so überglücklich dass wir
uns gefunden wonach hübsch mit einem
schönen und reichen
sag mir bitte nicht dass das die mutter
ist also der typ hatte anscheinend
gerade ein mädel zu besuch und ist mit
der gerade so auf date und flirtkurs und
jetzt kommt die mutter rein also mal
schauen wie die jetzt reagiert ist bei
mir aber auch immer so das müssen sie
das futter klingen
der dessous für seine freude bestellt
alles klar für eine neue freundin
jacqueline ein bisschen früh
jacqueline ist runtergefallen
das ist ja eine gummipuppe ich dachte
die ganze zeit das wäre ein richtiger
manager sitzen würde alte jacqueline
schön dich kennenzulernen die lieben und
so wie wir sind ja milchkaffee ja ist
als ersatzfrau da warst hast keine
freunde sturm heißt es da noch dass die
rede ist oder wenn meine freundin alter
wie redest du überhaupt mit meiner
freundin ist anders du wirst du sollst
immer dass ich eine richtige freundin ab
wir legen uns das ist doch alles für
äußerlichkeiten es kommt auch auf die
inneren werte an
ah ja die inneren werte von einer
gummipuppe also es kommt auf die luft in
der in der beziehung oder oder wie soll
ich das verstehen könnte so eine
klatsche bekommen dann klatschen hier
einiges
[Musik]
muster sagt schmidt und so eine glatze
der saga thor mit landrat der tür ein
ich finds echt feierlich wie
schlagkräftig dieser typ
schlagfertig ne
ja deutsch war noch nie so meine stärke
das tut mir so leid dass wir den ganzen
stress hier mitmachen musste
es tut mir leid dass die ganze pausieren
aber jetzt entschuldigt er sich bei
einer gummipuppe dafür dass sie den
stress mitmachen musste ich glaube
wirklich eine gummipuppe muss jetzt erst
mal die woche reha machen und ein
bisschen yoga augen zu entspannen
aber meine mutter wird sich auch schon
noch gewöhnen
[Musik]
ich weiß
du kannst nicht sehen dass das
kamerateam nicht übels nach fleisch
bekommen wir es nicht vorstellen kann
reden herr auf das powerbook zu küssen
ist da etwas nicht gemacht
ich weiß ja die luftmatratze ist und das
gefällt mir zum christentum petting
machen überhaupt nicht gut
moment ist er der neue therapeut
psychologie systemberater was letztes
mal irgendwie hatten wir uns mal an was
er zu sagen hat auch immer eine andere
person arbeitet das auch viel besser
geht er jetzt mit ihrer ok nach schon er
geht jetzt mit ihr ins bett oder so aber
hat ist ja das war gar nichts
ok alles floss jacqueline du sagst ja
gar nicht irgendwas falsch gemacht
ich liebe dich auch schon froh ich will
dir echt ich deine phantasie wegnehmen
aber das ist ein fucking gummipuppe die
hat keine gefühle keine emotionen und
hat auch gerade nicht geredet wieder
probleme mit dem neuen studio koffer
wenn ihr nicht so abfällig stubenhocker
maz etwas ganz besonderes ja also der
matte ist was ganz besonderes da weißt
du was gott lass uns ist weder einfach
ein bisschen gemütlicher okay ich sage
ganz ehrlich um erfahrungen zu machen da
kann jeder junge jedes mädchen gerne
auch so ein pool greifen sie alles in
ordnung und unsicher fühlt und so leute
ja und ich könnte mir selbst nicht
vorstellen ich ihnen so einen gegenstand
zu extrem zu verlieben hab ich
akzeptiere das voll und ganz wenn jemand
anders das möchte ich glaube dir das
auch ich hab auch regelmäßig jaklitsch
ich mit meiner luftmatratze rom daumen
hoch und dem video wenn ihr auch luft
man in eine luftmatratze
egal was mache ich hier im taxi auch
erst taxifahrer oder was jetzt zögert
die mutter war
matze ich muss das los hat ein rohrbruch
ein wasserschaden und gewürzen partei
bei uns wohnen sei bitte nett zu ihr
jahrhundert
roger war das richtig ist englisch ja
ich glaube die mutter will jetzt dass
die luzie bei dem wohnt so dass sich die
lucy dann vielleicht an ihrem so daran
macht und der sohn dementsprechend die
plastikpuppe jacqueline beck schweiz ja
oder vielleicht musst du sie wirklich
einmal bei den wohnhäusern robo haut
schnell ich musste gleich nochmal mit
johnny weg oma ist krank wir müssen ja
noch was vorbeibringen und herrlich
bitte so lange um lustig kümmern ich hab
das doch ewig nicht mehr gesehen
mensch ist matze soll sich also um lucia
kümmern
die pro-ge leiter ak gleich ein bisschen
das kochen ein bisschen fernseh gucken
vielleicht ist ja ein bisschen lust auf
mehr
alles klar einfach mal mutter
völlig normal hinzu eigentlich soll der
ganze scheiß
außerdem habe ich keinen freund von mir
vorbeikommt ein freund welcher freund
der titel habe ich aus den medien kennen
gelernt kilo ist ja nicht so dass mein
zweiter name mit tino also der matze hat
hier sichtlich keinen bock auf die lucy
obwohl die lose ziehen das hat man ja
ganz klar schon gemerkt haben nur
engagiert wurde sage ich mal damit sie
den mazda ein bisschen von der
plastikpuppe weg lockt aber ich bin mal
gespannt auf matzes kollegen der jetzt
rum kommen weil anscheinend hat er dann
doch richtige freunde im real life
das ist doch die beiden vielleicht etwas
trinken ich weiß nicht ob ich das rennen
nicht richtig checke aber also sein
kollege ist ein echter mensch war denn
auch seine puppe namens dolores
mitgenommen menschenrechte sind sämtlich
abstoßen hier ist das internet ist eine
hilfestellung leistung und wenn die
reihen sich zu kennen lernen und sozial
soziale kontakte kommen wäre das eine
supersache
das ist ab
danke für deine einschätzung an der
stelle
und doch ist das denn das was gucke ich
mir an dass die schmecken da los ja der
ist ja ich bin so froh ich kennengelernt
habe
ja man lieber was ich jetzt sagen dieses
forum richtig kennengelernt habt das war
wirklich meine rettung bin so froh dass
ich dich jetzt kenne und gegenüber dir
bin ich ihnen keine außenseiter unter
den spielwaren sind also versteh mich
nicht falsch wir können ja machen was
ihr wollt mit eurem püppchen aber
und ich habe
für uns alle es ist schon ein bisschen
verstört aber so geht macht euer ding
wie gesagt ich habe auch meine matratze
versuchen daher will ich das heute
wieder der stelle jetzt auch beenden
meine lieben freunde werden euch meine
wechseln auf diese hilfe folge gefallen
hat dann das unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier das schaffen wir
50.000 leicht das ist eine sehr hohe
zahl aber es wird mir auf jeden fall
zeigen euch hat es gefallen und der bock
auf mehr hilfe mehrerer actions falls
dem so jetzt könnt ihr mir gerne andere
folgen auf die ich reagieren soll und in
die kommentare schreiben abonniert zudem
gern meinen kanal falls sie noch kein
termin luxus sei das ist kostenlos und
da passt keine videos mehr und am 9 9
meine lieben freunde habe ich ja schon
gesagt kommt um 15 uhr neues merchandise
meinen shop unter anderem dieser rudi
also ich würd mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
da vorbeischauen würde
[Musik]